los principales líderes legislativos
republicanos del estado de michigan
estuvieron en la casa blanca este
viernes con el presidente de donald
trump detrás de la reunión que convocó
la jefa de prensa de la presidencia
podría estar una voluntad de revertir
los resultados en el estado de los
grandes lagos hay demandas muy reales
que la campaña está llevando a cabo 234
páginas de declaraciones juradas
disponibles al público en un solo
condado es el condado de wayne y dos
individuos en el comité de escrutinio
que se han negado a certificar después
de la reunión el líder de la mayoría del
senado de michigan mallorquín y el
presidente de la cámara de
representantes
lizette ford dijeron que seguirán la ley
y el proceso normal con respecto a los
electores que eligieron al demócrata joe
biden con más de 150.000 votos a favor
de ninguna legislatura estatal en la
historia de nuestro país ha hecho lo que
donald trump aparentemente agita para
que la legislatura estatal de michigan
haga que es ignorarlo
de una elección de voto popular y
arrebatar el control a los votantes o
intentarlo y nombrar a su propia lista
de electores para enviar a washington
washington las opciones de triunfo para
donald trump se estrechan con esta otra
derrota en pensilvania el candidato pide
que la elección sea totalmente
descartada por un posible fraude
cada estado tiene hasta el día 8 de
diciembre para resolver todas las
disputas y certificar sus resultados 16
días antes del resultado definitivo del
colegio electoral programado para el 14
de diciembre
[Aplausos]
[Música]